good morning Millenia good morning
millenials I just it just feels so good
to be back you know refreshed relaxed
renewed rejuvenation remember Ramona
Singer it's just true renewal true
renewal whatever it was when when she
was on a rejuvenation yes and she was in
the in the boat in the white bikini and
like stick with károly abs yeah always
sticks her belly out when she walks
I mean it's a lot to look she looks
great so maybe that's what we have to do
stake our bellies and then at 60 we'll
look like 25 perhaps we'll give it a
shot
I'm a 25 year old who looks like a six
year old and then maybe when I'm 60 I'll
look 25 I'm a 25 year old who feels like
a 60 year old wow that's old I feel like
an 80 year old really I mean especially
because yesterday I walked and yesterday
was the most treacherous a life it's
crazy that today is not Monday it's
actually Thursday it's only been one day
since I was I sitting here but we have
yet to see you since your trip elevator
pitch how was it oh it was great last
minute you guys know last week I was
like all turnt up about where I should
go right and obviously the weather ended
up being fine in Puerto Rico but it I
think I didn't really check but I didn't
hear anything about it so I'm sure it
was fine I just really wanted to
experience something new and I've never
been to Cancun I've only been to Mexico
once and it was a year ago with Paltrow
but this year I went to a different part
and when I went we can either Paltrow it
was a one stop light and honestly I
loved ones Paltrow but even she's not
worth of one stoplight
in Mexico with a layover in like Mexico
City so this was better as trek fly
JetBlue empty flight empty flight there
was a seat between me and been like the
dream and it was just lovely I had a
really relaxing time I only got drunk
for like two of the four nights that I
was there and that's I really felt
relaxed like the other two nights um and
it was just lovely you know there was
not one person at the hotel
it was obviously off-peak but it was
like off-off-off peaking me in bed work
night dream there was this other group
afford that may meant like we're fully
convinced were swingers but our hotel
what's next to the hotel called secrets
you were telling I said apparently is
this I think it's a swingers hotel
because their commercials are very
suggestive and they're never gonna come
right out and say like hey this is a
swingers hotel but it's adults only and
all the commercials are like girls
rolling around on the beach like having
Morgan here a swinger like you'll pick
up
right like it's an odd taste when it's
Morse code it's like swingers you know
and then I mean it was amazing and
wonderful but oh my god the most crazy
thing happened to me the airport did I
tell you I don't think so I have to talk
to gbg about this because I need to know
if I was in the wrong Ben was convinced
that I was in the wrong so we landed at
5:35 twenty minutes early which is great
because we literally planned our trip so
poorly it was like an hour and a half
before the holiday started come keep or
it's like we really used to get home
from JFK holidays because it's a
celebration holiday but this is a touch
on the tour today
and so we get to the plane first of all
we got there twenty minutes early they
didn't have anyone gets to the jet
bridge for 20 minutes so like the 20
minutes I had made up
I just lost again I was so annoyed and
you know my [ __ ] ass was the first
person off the plane like in the first
route like running and we get to customs
and I was at this magical terminal at
JFK have you ever been to Terminal five
at JFK I don't think so as someone who's
often been at Terminal four getting
dropped off at b51 the longest walk ever
I was so excited to let it be televised
so we get to me men are being crazy but
like running to the machine we do the
little machine like we take the picture
and then they have like a big line for
US citizens and it's completely I'm sure
it's always the scariest picture and
what's scarier is that like if you ever
commit like a heinous heinous crime
that's what I make sure they'll use
because that's like you don't have a
mugshot like that's your official photo
so if I get arrested the picture is
gonna be me literally and then in the
background like literally monitoring for
me he said go longer shorter do any of
you commit like a couple's crime that
picture will be Italian cloud make sure
we really tell a tale so there's like
the longest wavy line but there's nobody
in it so like Ben is like like an
[ __ ] you know and I'm like [ __ ] this
I gotta go so I walk underneath like a
normal person and that customs agent
goes like this I honestly thought he was
kidding he was like excuse me what are
you doing I'm like me he goes who do you
think you are I was like girls nice
hosts in the morning token he was like
who do you think you are I dead I
thought he was kidding like and I'm like
I couldn't tell he was yelling at me for
me you couldn't possibly be yelling at
me for walking underneath the thing when
there's no mind that yeah that's just
nonsensical and he was like go back
around like I felt like a two-year a
two-year old
in kindergarten getting in trouble I had
to like go around go underneath again
walk around like I hang my head in shame
and when I got up there he's like
literally still yelling I mean even
though he just publicly shamed me he's
like what are you doing you did such a
big rush can't wait and then here they
asking weird questions like you know
where you're from where'd you go what do
you do
so he's like what do you do and I was
afraid to answer cuz I thought I think
he might have thought I was being like a
[ __ ] like because he just yeah
facetious yes she goes what do you do
and I'm like I'm a comedian and he's
like okay cuz like and then I got ready
and he's like next time don't rush and I
was like well you know it's a Jewish
holiday so I didn't we're in a kind of a
big rush because we were delayed and I
wanted him to like take me further so I
could claim anti-semitism but he let it
go once he say Jewish you know people
just let you go because we love to
comport they know we love to come oh
that's true Hitler on the other hand he
didn't care and then Ben was like how
dare you talk back to a customs agent
I'm like what no seriously that you
can't trash-talking a customs agent oh
my god like if you're under a brush
required for sure but like it's gonna
they have this sense of power like
people at the DMV who make like young
girls cry just cuz they got in the wrong
line but people did you like don't have
any like legal power like they can trust
you no but like in that room they have
all the power and they can stop you from
getting your permit which could be
really hard for some people
no but like it was - Ben was like no you
can't you can't trash-talk a customs
agent and here's the thing like
personally I think I would have done the
zigzags just cuz I'm a rule follower but
I also am a miniature person so I also
that's my one time in life to shine it's
just to tear through them but see here's
the thing Ben was just being again
facetious because whenever Ben gets
pulled over by the cops which is
literally all the time he loves to like
beats like snide you know what I mean
laughs oh my god are you kidding yeah
right so I'm always saying to him I'm
like Ben are you for real like have
respect for the law and Ben's always
like the police officers like you know
how fast we were going he said yeah 35
what he was like literally going seven
eight so Ben like trouble he is my
argument against me now he's like you
can be rude to customs agent I'm like
first of all he was rude to me and I
don't do anything other than answer his
questions yeah I mean technically you're
in the wrong because like you weren't
following the rules but it's an abuse of
power and I and I won't stand for that
speaking of abuse of power have you
got a new piece of jewelry or like
fashion or shoes and like it's just
completely changed to urs awesome and
it's like wow people think of me
differently too now precisely sister
that's me now because I like acted
surprised but I did pick it out and like
everything with my friend Otto who works
with Stephanie godly fine jewelry but
been you know handled the finances and
now I just this ring that I got for my
one-year anniversary like I am
completely like a changed person really
no okay
as much as technically you would think
that piece of jewelry wouldn't change
who you are like this really does cuz
now your wedding ring situation like
tells a story it's like not only am I an
engaged woman I'm a married woman I have
a diamond ring on both hands which means
I'm like plotting to be a housewife
that's a housewife hand you know I'm not
one step closer to Bethenny Frankel
Jackie he's so much to catch and Julian
lock-ins here today you guys she just
knocked on our door yeah hope you guys
are free till noon yeah people keep you
here till noon we can't keep the path
forward um let me say oh I'm saying with
this new ring I'm one step closer to
Bethenny Frankel but I am one step
closer about that if I go anyway because
like my life changed over the weekend
because you're not being strong well you
know I did want to use my platform for
good which I always do and I just never
know what organizations are reliable
these days cuz everyone is just like
sleuthing and stealing money I took you
Joe did you get Red Cross and it's like
you donate five dollars in like ten
cents goes to like the actual person who
needs it it's like so [ __ ] up and now
I'm watching billions and all this like
venture philanthropy they literally say
how they just like raise money to spend
it to keep raising it but they I'm not
out here accusing the Red Cross I was
just using as an example I'm sure the
Red Cross gives like 90 percent of their
proceeds because you never know I need
you you never know so I just feel like a
barian
Micah Bethenny on the ground just like
give literally every dollar know you
know where your money's going you see it
on TV and I like when you donate you can
literally pick what cause to donate to
so it's like hurricane relief or when
there was multiple hurricanes you could
have picked specific regions so you know
being the Good Samaritan that I am I
just put it on my Instagram story and I
was gonna do it anyway and I was
obviously being like a little thirsty
just doing it for like that knees
because I could have done with like you
know
peed up which I should have because I
don't know but you're you're the flip
the philanthropic side of it cancels out
the thirsty side right okay yeah I'm not
gonna lie like I was being thirsty but I
also would have done it even if it was
right and we did raise some money so
whatever but then she message me on
Instagram and had a cat when she
followed me oh so now you have a direct
line yeah and identity you said already
like Harris I also thought follow me on
Instagram for years and I haven't abused
the DM because like I'm waiting for the
perfect moment and Bethany like within
the first five minutes I Renae via said
I made like a joke and she like didn't
respond
she's busy it was a pertinent joke it's
fine like I'm you approved it I did know
and it's good okay you're just like
you'll make your mark didn't worry
nothing you slow and steady wins the
race you're not just gonna over and I
have a friendship but like now you're
building up in the DM z-- you see her
out once and then you'll see you'll see
okay you have to build these things
that's true it's like a home you have to
build a strong foundation how was your
fast my fast was I was so nervous about
it which is still weird I had women
talking about it and also the only thing
that was like worse than the fast was
all the hype around it like I had so
much adrenaline in my stomach like
thinking I wasn't gonna make it for some
reason and I was actually okay we had um
a decent sized dinner on Tuesday night
and when I got home I like we plates
categories for like 5 hours so we got
home around like midnight and then I
watched your episode civilians and fell
asleep do you feel reinvigorated when it
comes to games because I'm a very game
oriented person anytime we take a trip I
always have a deck of cards I have one
in my purse right now I like heart I
love games
I just like can't get enough of games I
just put in new games called code names
oh my god we're gonna play it Knights
began just such a great game I love
games I love Jenga I love it all and
Jackie [ __ ] hates games anytime I
bring one out she litter goes to her
room and locks herself I did like she
hates games it's so annoying I do and I
love things and I've come around I've
come to realize what I do and don't like
about them seeing with Broadway shows
where I swore I would never see a
Broadway show again after that Ray's
Incident of the dog in the night I mean
that was traumatizing that was
traumatizing and it honestly should be
illegal and I took a 3-year hiatus but
then I realized because I really wanted
to see Book of Mormon for some reason I
saw it and no I wanted to see Dr of
enhancing because you were really like
shoving it down my throat and I saw
whoo harmony and I saw dear Ivan Hansen
and I really enjoyed it but it made me
realize that I want to see a big
production I want to see the works
annexed like camera action like I don't
want to see anything close to a play
like I need every moment of the musical
to be like the most expensive like
blockbuster musicals so then I did see
Book of Mormon and it was that and now I
know what I do and don't like about
musicals and I will see the next big you
want the glitz in the glam 42nd Street
pubs I want [ __ ] 42nd Street like I
once have dancers I want to hear the
sounds of March easy I'm having you I'm
taking you to 42nd Street
okay wait also okay it's I'd like
scattegories because it's an equal
playing fields we all have the same
information and we have to like answer
the same question it's and it's really
like a true test of knowledge whereas we
play Trivial Pursuit a lot which I
[ __ ] hate because it's all about luck
and if you get a question that like
maybe you heard once on like Downton
Abbey yeah no we just got like one in
every ten questions is multiple choice
but just some regular pair but still
like I don't [ __ ] know who won that
Wimbledon in 1982 came in second place
even like that's the kind of questions
they ask yeah we were any man alive
Trivial Pursuit also speaking of
productions
I'm like so late to the game because
like people have been telling me to
watch Curb Your Enthusiasm for at BER
and like being one of them yeah and it's
slowly like now in season four just like
over the years I've started watching it
but now I'm like diving in and headfirst
because there's a whole season with
David Schwimmer friends Ross Geller he
goes on Broadway with Larry David in the
producers and they're the two guys
watching it and I jumped in at a certain
point oh oh my god Jackie it's so funny
and it's so weird to see now that I'm
thinking about it I've never seen David
Schwimmer play anything other than
friends except for when he played Robert
Kardashian but I didn't even look like
himself so I don't consider that
anything like I've never seen I like I
don't know David Schwimmer I know Ross
Geller do you know what I mean so ever
to see Ross Geller with like Larry David
and you know there are a few kirb
episodes with Moira she's out of control
it's so funny did you finish the season
shits Creek no I'm waiting for it to be
on Netflix I bought it on my on iTunes
so like every time I travel I watch like
one episode it's good it's like I feel
like now that everyone knows it's funny
like it's
funny whereas when we knew about it like
Susan Juan it was so fun it was so funny
but it's just it's still better than
nothing you know like the amount of TV
shows that I watch like is getting
smaller and smaller
so I'm excited about shits Peter I
Netflix I was trying to watch episode by
episode like on pop it wasn't where it's
a bit in show okay pop except now that I
switched over to spectrum because I
moved into my new palace where that
which has a mirror in the kitchen I
think that I might get pop which could
change my life no I have it mom
oh you have spectrum no I'm YouTube TV
there's pop oh and it didn't change your
life no I will start recording episodes
of [ __ ] squeak when I get back but well
I hope my new subscription gets me fused
Network because they play The Nanny on
it and every time I'm I told TV I would
click it and it's a starting on this
channel then Annie
honestly justice for friend Drescher
justice for Viva Josh her cuz she was
writing about having a ghostwriter and
she's that is so true you have your
gobble over there I do we're here to
serve Samaritan yes why we haven't used
it in a while
you gotta clean the desktop and also we
need to fix this engraving because it
says award-winning co-host for the
morning breath so we're gonna serve some
justice for Aviva Drescher cuz while she
was crazy and didn't necessarily need to
throw her leg at Lacerte well she was
right about writer girl about Carol
having a ghostwriter which we found out
like in the most innocent way wasn't
even like a salacious things right I
found out like from a true source in the
publishing industry
it's not even wasn't you being salacious
it just said it's a skank as fact and
also justice for Aviva Drescher because
she invented the phrase writer girl and
like we use it all the time and we use
it all the time and like you know what
if no one was taking me seriously I
might throw a leg down yeah if I had one
to throw at litter
consider it sir okay I think that's a
good segue until we wrap up everything
we needed to wrap up well you know if we
did it it'll come to us okay but we have
a we have a long show today so we can't
just get it all out on TSA agents
without further ado here are the Fast
Five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast so I didn't count
calc aps onion sorry to the podcasters
listening I'm like squeaking my chair a
lot
oh it's okay the podcasters like because
Lauren Elizabeth came on the show mm-hmm
I guess was two days ago feels like a
month ago and she is an avid toast
listener she listened to every single
episode she know every story that we
were talking about like she knew
everything and she loves the [ __ ] that
we need to like more business and her
story she was like with Cameron and ever
and like her friends like she knows
everything because I guess like the guys
were talking about how Apple was the
only US company to be one Chilean she's
like wait um since she said the podcast
audio it like is really low sometimes
and we've now corrected it oh my god so
you're welcome podcast listeners okay
also how was Lauren Elizabeth she was
great did she do a good job it's hard to
find a good co-host it's hard to find a
good co-host these days she was great
she's such a pro and like we just like
have the exact same interest oh really
yeah
that's so interesting yeah the only
thing like that I talked about was
Nashville that she doesn't watch which I
completely understand yeah nobody does
right right that's why I went from ABC
to CMT to six feet to De Aza
yeah okay first story that popped up
yesterday maroon 5 is set to perform at
the 2019 Super Bowl halftime show
hello it I'll allow it it's better than
Justin Timberlake but it's still not my
dream realized of JLo and pitbull which
just makes complete sense oh that is a
good one right that's what I've been
predicting every year okay I mean this
just gets me annoyed because I don't
really feel like the person who gets
picked for the Super Bowl is ever like
in their moment do you know what I mean
like except when they did Bruno Mars but
I really feel like Bruno Mars this
moment was like a year later but like
and it's also annoying because I can't
take the stereo sickest Elish with will
never do the halftime show because she
is a diet coke person and the halftime
show Pepsi so that's why she put on that
show at Houston last year before the
Superbowl so it's like I always wanted
to be tell us but it's never ever gonna
be Taylor Swift like until she's out of
her package Pepsi cotton even when she's
out of her Coke contract it could be a
few years later right
so can
about that but here's the thing was this
the year of maroon 5 no no and also I
feel like they were ahead of the curve
on Bruno Mars almost you know like he
hadn't peaked yet and usually they wait
till like someone's over the hill of
their career to bring them on I mean yes
I think the one time they really hit the
nail on the head in recent history was
Lady gaga yeah and she recorded
five-foot to the documentary while she
was doing it so like that was just like
an epic year for her
yeah and subsequently like she didn't
fall from grace like she's still living
her best life I think that was a great
decision I could have really lived
without Justin Timberlake like talk
about not being in tune with the
American people in their needs because I
couldn't care less right also they got
Katy Perry before her fall from grace we
but yes but like I think they even got
Katy Perry before she was as big as she
could have been no because they got her
got her ISM and then she went into
witness it's so much better that they
got her at that exact time when she was
like still having hits because no one
listened to witness and they had her now
these like songs no one ever heard and
they also hit the nail on the head when
they did they did Beyonce like so long
ago now at this point and she's still
like peaking okay well of course I mean
she's an anomaly she doesn't count right
but and I really did black eyed peas
like that was so sad no it's just like I
feel like it's really sad that like
there's every year they must be like
grasping at straws to do someone they
haven't done before right Beyonce has
now done it twice because she came on
with Coldplay and Bruno Mars yeah so
it's like there's so few people who are
like you can't lip-synch like you really
can't and you have to Diaz you have to
deliver like a multimedia you know kind
of show you got to dance you got to sing
you out of torque you got to do all the
things so there are so few people who
are actually good at what they do that
like I bet it's hard it's okay that's
why maroon 5 safe choice very safe
choice but here are some options for the
future I really wonder why Carrie
Underwood hasn't done it yet because she
is the NFL totally oh Sunday night but
because you want to know why the Super
Bowl is so mainstream it's not even like
country football and she yes she is like
the big star of country and people know
who she is in America but they don't
know her songs I think that if she did a
halftime show people would realize how
many of their song how many of her songs
they actually do know I mean if you
stand on the boats got to beat set clap
got a real good feeling something bad
about to a dresser would be so epic and
let's just so football but maybe they're
saving her I don't know also I think in
a few years time
has pink done it no she would be amazing
yes she's perfect for it she's yeah
because she's like she's not she's in
her climax but it's like she's
plateauing at her class she has like a
catalog of greatest hits totally um we
should one day maybe in like three years
ariana grande could do it oh yeah I mean
she's so young the national anthem
lassie right honey usually like wouldn't
Lady gaga sing the national anthem the
next year she like they want to prove
that you can like not maybe they should
have Fergie do it who's singing the
national anthem I think they should have
you do it I think so too
I mean I've actually anthem is really
like the most important part to me pink
we were at the Super Bowl last year and
we will be there this year so this is
like as I guess I'm gonna Marin five
concert but uh but not really because
it's so made-for-tv yeah here's the
thing that least I'll enjoy it like
Justin Timberlake we literally went to
the bathroom like that was the one that
was the worst part of the Super Bowl his
back was towards us and we were in the
front like no bad seats his back was
towards us I couldn't hear anything and
he was like so busy desecrating Prince's
memory that's what we have to go to the
bar so much I want to say something
mildly controversial here for it I think
that only took you 20 minutes I think
that girls like you is like one of the
best songs really like I listened to an
travursel and I'm like damn this is a
Bop and you don't snitch tell me because
she like tells me on my good information
this song came out like a while ago and
nobody cared until they redid it with
cardi B huh and that's just like cardi B
bringing new things to life I think that
they will have someone come on as a
cameo because it's not like Lady Gaga
who's one person who's gonna take all
this time for herself and she should
like it's for people they're already
splitting the spotlight what's one more
and by the way they're hardly splitting
the spotlight there's Adam Levine and
then there's three other guys one of the
minor is it even three other people oh I
don't know
I don't know I just feel like bands are
always for people yeah but like I would
put girls like you live Murray oh that
make sense I would put girls like you up
there with the men to bees of this of
2018 it's not the greatest song of all
time but like of the year it's like I
can listen to it and I'll probably be
able to listen to it for another year
without getting annoyed which is really
tough for me oh wow I completely just
like it it's not a song like it's a song
that plays on the radio that I don't
enjoy oh I mean that if it's played
enough times I begin to enjoy but at its
core the music video right God the dough
did you see it no oh my god it's so good
first of all it's literally just like
one screen and it's Adam Levine and they
just have like famous women who are like
killing it they had
in Aly Raisman like they just like it's
cool yeah and then they ended with like
Behati and the kid like it was really
cute I like and he's like very in tune
with what's necessary and like 20:18
like and honestly not too long ago I was
dancing with Dallas you know it's really
really if I let you me my mama right
when the red light red light stop
I don't play when it comes to my heart
Nicki Minaj I can't I feel like any time
I talk about Nicki Minaj I get y'all
better on Twitter but like I'm so not
here for Nicki Minaj and people are like
why don't you talk about the cardi B
Nicki Minaj saying and like [ __ ] we did
it's on our patreon you better go to
kake.com
but I'm so like I'm so done with Nicki
Minaj for so many reasons like I mean
what they say about her in the lines and
I only take lines at face value because
sometimes they are exaggerations of the
truth but just from what I see as like a
consumer I'm not into her like at all I
think she's a mean girl I think she
starts fights with people and like with
organizations and like I'm just I'm I
really find her like to be really
irritating and I always get in trouble
for saying that I don't know why like I
hurt in normanni like the kid you know
you can't say anything bad about her
mind yeah I know I'm like who's just one
song I was supposed to say she's an
ex-fiance someone literally said she was
next Beyonce I was like excuse me why
thank you um I like Nicki Minaj but when
it comes to Nicki Minaj versus cardi B
cardi every time but I'd like to ignite
tonight and I like her music I like when
they give me not Minaj did for females
in the RMD space but but now she's
making it like she can be the only woman
it's just like there's room for all of
us yeah oh I had a thought cuz like now
this has me thinking because when you
said I should sing the national anthem
I've made a decision that you are gonna
go on American Idol no um it's so
interesting that you say that because
it's actually the opposite that you're
gonna record a jam oh no I am going to
let go of my dream of being a singer I
thought you already did and that's why
you've only seen on this show well no I
feel like I've always like held that
hope for like really like doing the
Super Bowl halftime show and like you're
lying but like I really feel like you
can only have so many callings in life
and I feel like I've really found my
calling being a Comique and like I as
much as I am a good singer I'm not like
an amazing I'm no you know Carrie
Underwood I'm no Fergie that's a sound
but like I really I don't know I feel
like I've always thought that I have
like this most amazing voice and like I
did yeah I had a great voice like for
singing when I'm like drunk you know but
like I just really I'm letting it go
okay
I'm gonna say cuz like the little girl
inside me is like but we know but it's
like what we always say on the show it's
like not everyone on American Idol even
with a good voice is meant to be a
singer like being having a good voice is
something you are born with at a certain
point in life like it's not gonna happen
for you it's a cool party trick and like
just cuz I'm a good dancer doesn't mean
I should go on world of dance right and
just because you have like a decent
singing voice doesn't mean you should
like make your biker and not provide for
your family and I just try and make it
as a musician while your kid is like
silently suffering and I feel like you
are really me like you use your vocal
ability like in your regular life right
like you're a comic you use it on your
shows no totally it's a party trick yeah
like a toy party I really felt like in
my soul and in my heart like I really
thought I was gonna make it and like I'm
letting it go so why is someone Scott
child's something I think is it from
well your baby it's fairly suffocating
in the next room I think it's from Sex
in the City Miranda yells at Steve for
keeping condoms in the baby bag oh well
I don't think it'd fall success you're a
starving artist does not mean your child
is defecate no I was making a joke just
making trying to culturally relevant but
yeah I just I want to make an official
announcement I'm letting go okay but
that's not gonna stop how much you
should actually probably know it's not
gonna start how much I'm saying but like
I'm really gonna stop you did say you
were trying to like get someone to scout
you on this show that's why you're gonna
sing so much I was gonna use this as a
platform like this is what we always say
like honestly I know everyone thinks
this is like a little Instagram show but
everyone in the world watches the chest
and if you ever want anything done you
come on the chest and you say you put it
on the universe and someone who works
for some company it's gonna give it to
you
so like I'm going to that cheering
concert this weekend with Margo because
I got take it off me circa like you just
what do you want oh we're a little more
lowbrow than that yeah I would say more
like Michael Cordes you know yeah well I
did get it that closing bag so we're
somewhere it's like you just have to put
it out on the toast so that's what I was
doing with my singing voice but I'm
officially saying for all the record
label executives listening I'm no longer
interested great but Jerry Seinfeld I
have a treat for you because someone is
watching who you want is who I know you
want to
- Samantha Wayne Samantha Wayne was one
of the I spoke to Samantha Wayne over
the weekend in the bps no not one of the
but Renee yeah they were so many I mean
Samantha Wayne I can't even talk about
the time we had together because I just
I know too much about you but I Love You
Samantha Wayne and I really hope you
come back to Kim to us thanks here you
have to if you don't come we're
canceling it yes no pressure anything
yet okay
next story have we only done one yes we
gotta keep it's waiting and Lee Ann
waits for nobody right Kelly Clarkson
talk show picked up by except relations
rich oh my god same thing Kelly Clarkson
is venturing into the daytime talk arena
NBC own television station group has
picked up the Kelly Clarkson show from
NBC Universal domestic Television
Distribution Clarkson will host shyam
Brandon Blackstock will serve as
executive producers I am so [ __ ] here
for they I love her so much she's so
funny her hosting abilities at the BBM
a's just yeah that she is so cut out for
this totally and I just London she's
like diverse defying her career even
though she doesn't need to because she's
actually one of the voices of our
generation someone who could perform the
Super Bowl halftime show but just
perform the national anthem and I love
you so much Kelly I just about like four
front row concert tickets to your show
yeah they were very expensive and then
Jackie sent me event motocross for it I
actually I did and I'm not that petty
but I just know like they were expensive
so I just need everyone to pay me up
front I know people are gonna drop out
because no one wants go to Uniondale and
I can still wanna get stuck with the
bells so pay me now totally but then if
I don't go it's like on my own loss and
I live with them right but it like I'm
not taking the hit just because I was
proactive and not the presale code yet
posters thank you so much
I mean with the name like Kelly Clarkson
if you don't end up working in daytime I
just I think you're not doing the right
thing with your life and I'm so here for
it and I just find it so interesting the
people you know we've been thinking a
lot about recently um Harry Connick jr.
closed Rachael Ray cliff Rachael Ray has
the most successful daytime television
show and nobody talks about it
she's just quietly cashing those checks
while you know putting a little parmesan
on everything she is making so much
money
anyone drew my thought about her because
I was home shopping on my Wayfair app as
I do every day and I saw this vanity and
like oh damn it so cute and then it was
$1,200 I'm like wait it's not that cute
who makes it Rachael Ray she is the most
diverse brand of like home look just
home but like
food furniture lifestyle television
celebrity lately she just killed it and
I'm I just like forgot that her show was
on the air because it's just steadily
successful you never know her steady
wins the race you ever hear about like
her ratings you know breaking the glass
ceiling but you never hear about you
know like ants later like megan kelly
type ratings it's like it's just steady
the viewers get what they want the
advertisers get what they want
everyone's happy like I just loved her
and I think that Kelly Clarkson could be
a Rachael Ray vibe because they both are
just like loved by middle America like
they're made fun of in the press cuz
like they're just women doing it for
themselves but like they don't care like
they get they get the viewership in the
hearts of the people who really matter
not as elitist on the East Coast I'm the
people who really matter also what's
interesting about Rachael Ray is so show
her show was on the Food Network which
is part of Scripps correct and because
she was so successful she came out with
all these like satellite lines and
everything scripts like she was the
first person to really do that scripts
didn't know to take a piece of it and
definitely the Rachael Ray everyone in
the scripts family here after has a
piece of their business like taken by
Scripps which is about you have mojo
alright didn't sign another contract cuz
they want to like have a hundred percent
well that's like Bravo yeah when they
first started housewives when Bethenny
sold for a hundred fifty million dollars
they didn't have that little clause now
they call it the Bethenny clause where
everyone who signs up if you happen to
get on the show and make a million
dollar business which it's never gonna
happen again
except maybe our country million dollar
business you can make okay so that's
like 1 million ok a multi-million dollar
business well that's two million okay
like how about seven figures eight
figures an eight-figure dollar business
except what do you think about the the
that's that is around like Erika Jayne
cuz like she's not making a business but
herself is becoming a business and like
she's getting more tickets sold to her
shows affect his probably got a piece of
that you know I think like she's not
coming out with her own makeup line but
she's doing a big collab with Too Faced
right I don't know I feel like no cuz
it's like messy but like how would they
draw the lines there they don't take a
piece of everyone's just life
interesante so maybe she found to work
around because she's a smart [ __ ] yeah
just here I mean Tom would not let her
sign any document that is not Erin
Brokovich approved right but Kelly
Clarkson is coming to TV perpend
honestly I think it's like I was reading
somewhere that she's competing with
soaps which mean she'll be on in the
afternoon which is just perfect for me
because we're not competing with her so
like she can come on our show in the
morning and we can go on hers in the end
you guys can watch Kelly Clarkson and
the toast don't worry I just I find it
very interesting who succeeds in daytime
television well they still yet to be
seen oh no I know I'm just saying I was
like a bigger Baxter I'm predicting a a
wild success here but like okay
Bethany flop I could have told you that
she was not nearly as I come all back
then and you she's she's skinny I'm
sorry you can't be that skinny and have
a show on daytime Tyra will she's
accessible for a little bit okay I just
don't remember like if it's over then
it's not a success right met at meredith
vieira I just feel like not in tune with
other people wanted I couldn't really
have cared bus also Harry Connick jr.
doing okay place at the nail salon uh
got cancelled no literally like as as I
was talking about you know like a curse
Jackie as like some girls Jeff's like
I'm a pretty set for Harry Connick
literally I she was right in the email
they got cancelled that's just like us I
didn't like Ellen supreme but like Ellen
is revolutionary and I really feel so
stuck about Ellen because I love her
I just think she's so epic and like I
just love her show I think they do such
good work like with Walmart and I think
her just like being as successful as she
is she really was like a pioneer for the
lgbtq+ community but what I know about
her like her being the biggest [ __ ] of
all time and like literally being evil
and having blood coming out of her eyes
like I'm torn I'm definitely torn and
also I could be watching certain
interviews like the one with me Singh
Ramsay like and she was so me she was
[ __ ] on his dreams of going to
college like yo problem jack he has a
public service announcement about mr.
Ramsay oh I did well Jack he put
something into text the other day and
like I'm thinking you're meaning to be
funny but like no I was just trying to
make you understand how I felt so
obviously everyone says protect at all
costs now which are just like for
English words strung together so we
didn't invent them but we definitely
popularized the term and I remember the
first time I said it and it was while we
were in Turks and Caicos I was drunk on
Margo sad talk remember when we were in
Turks and Caicos that's when famous came
out and I was just like what a cherub I
was just like on a mason high and I was
just thinking about Mason all the time
and this song was just so pure and
beautiful and it confirmed everything I
thought I knew about him and that like I
just I just wanted to be there for him
and I just wanted him to be protected
and I said I'm Margo Sam
drunk so like it really was just my
drunk words I was like protect Mason
Ramsey at all cost and then from there
that became our thing and now everyone's
like you know protect Chris Hemsworth at
all costs even though if he can protect
himself then we're the rest of us are
and so needs no protection even protects
them and everyone's like protect this
person protect that person but no
protect me some Ramsey because like he
was just singing at Walmart and went
viral and then was thrown into the
spotlight nothing of which he sought out
and now he's like a young boy in the
Hollywood machine and we all know how
that turns out so we're just trying to
protect him from all of these forces
that he didn't go out seeking when
you're saying like protect like this
young actor actually say protect young
Milly Bobby Brown like she don't need
protection she like sought out a career
in acting she's at the Emmy Awards and
she's missing she want her and her stage
mom knew what they were getting time
they had agents and managers and people
who they pay to protect them like Mason
Ramsay has his grandparents and now
Florida Georgia line thank God but like
we need to protect him because he did
not choose his life everyone else that
you're telling us to protect chose this
and is prepared for this Mason is not
furthermore if you're gonna use that
phrase use it correctly that's right
that's all I'm saying but the critical
is so straight a dissertation unlike why
it is different from every other case of
protection it's become so popular but
being used incorrectly and that's what's
so frustrating about it right right and
it's like everyone who says protect at
all costs like no it's not that they're
toasters and they watch the show but
like we said it enough that one person
said it then the next person said and
now it's just like in the public arena
of being said so it's not like they're
copying directly from us but it's
started here with Mason that's right
it's fine but use it correctly
yeah okay next story Khloe Kardashian is
moving back to Cleveland for Tristan
Thompson and Jackie oz right Khloe
Kardashian
Jackie are you gonna move to Cleveland
up like this definitely helps it pushes
up your moving date 8s it definitely
pushes on my movie date except I keep
talking about Cleveland on my Instagram
story and I just cannot spell it right
for the life of him like Cleve like
cleavage see even I think that people
the good people of Cleveland are getting
fed up with CLE de land I keep saying CL
EA ve land cleavage land we've hours
logged ya know Cleveland and for those
who don't know Jackie's considering
moving to Cleveland packing up her
things because she just can't deal with
the the vessel impossibility the hustle
and the traffic of New York City so
Cleveland is probably better suited for
her needs and if you
watch my Instagram story was sound the
other day which it's okay somebody works
so like I don't blame you but I was in
my apartment and I heard like a mouse a
hundred percent a mouse and I was just
like literally on street easy like
Cleveland like we're gone we're done and
then I realized it was my seltzer like
making a hissing noise so we'll stay
here for now but I just I've seen like a
lot of cockroaches and I saw one little
earlier in my dreams when you and Zach
went to get Academy and then walked I
literally saw one ten steps later and Bo
tried to eat it and now I'm getting
paranoid like now I'm like shutting off
like my toilet and I say yeah like
drains because their every water bugs
because I was thinking like how would a
liitle cockroach like climb his way up
to a high floor like that doesn't makes
pipes pipes but pipes go straight up
wouldn't he fall back down no no the
only thing that could survive a nuclear
war is cockroaches did you know I do
know that I do so they could survive a
[ __ ] pipe and it would like gravity
can they get in their boxes they hide
they can fit any literally they can fit
anyway it's so discussing and I have an
exterminator come once a month inventing
some crazy he's like you know how many I
need his number I haven't had this
amazing like I haven't seen anything but
it's just like I know it's coming and he
comes during the day and my doorman
definitely thinks I'm like having an
affair with my exterminator and like he
died is doing me a favor by not telling
then I'm like no he's really an
exterminator anyways speaking of
extermination Chloe and Tristan and
their daughter two are moving back to
Cleveland in June the 34 year old
Keeping Up with the Kardashians star in
the 27 year old Cleveland Cavaliers
which is another reason why I want to
move to Cleveland so I can support the
Theo's yeah the but the Cavaliers like
how [ __ ] cute
I know Theo is just everything these
days I don't know like what's he's
drinking but like he's looking fine well
he went to camp and you know when you
like go to camp and you start like
hanging like acting like your friend
yeah like I talked the same way you use
the same weird verbiage that's kind of
probably how people feel about the toast
Theo goes to camp and picks up you know
different traits so he has been humping
non-stop I don't know where he learned
that not my house that's what people do
learn at camp oh yeah everyone's having
sex yeah totally so Chloe interest in
flee with their the baby from the city
where she was born to the
kardashian-jenner hub of LA the three
have lived at Chloe's house is summer
during the Emmy offseason as they can
Patterson's cheating scandal which
errupted just before she was born
chloe is planning on moving back to
Cleveland with Tristan in the next few
weeks they are doing better and have had
a more positive summer so I mean so did
China them because I can't even talk
about that right morning but we like
England is the opposite of childhood
negates Beach hiding the great China of
2000 China here's the thing it's Chloe's
life do I really care now so do whatever
you want if that means less traffic for
me next time I'm in LA you know I'm cool
with that right as long as you're
filming and churning out premium content
cool I do think though it's really very
telling about like the type of celeb
people celebrities are depending on
where they live I think that every
celebrity who lives in New York is a lot
more down-to-earth they're not
necessarily the nicest people because
they can still be mean but like I just
think where you live as a celebrity says
a lot about you celebrities who aren't
country music stars who live in
Nashville are way more down-to-earth ins
the mainstream celebs who live in LA so
one who lives in Cleveland I think she
just has to be the most sound her right
I feel like she's really trying to make
as normal of a life for herself and her
baby as possible yeah I mean once you
have a child it's like it's all real
it's like everything that's been leading
up to it is fake and now you need to
protect your child at all costs right
because they can't protect themselves
because their children they need
protection at all costs because they
can't protect themselves unlike some
people who can protect themselves just
something to think about just a little
just a little sprinkle of knowledge um
next story good for thought let's go now
into our business of the day and um oh
let me let me set up straight
business news what's going on in stock
today Oh we'll get to that but a new JD
Power Report is listing the best and
worst airports Las Vegas Orlando and
John Wayne are tops
what's John Wayne I'm strong up Fung
Jung Baghdad
don't I don't know where John Wayne is I
feel like it's in Vegas but they already
said Las Vegas well what is it basing it
on okay air travelers say they are the
happiest they've been in years when
flying through US airports according to
JD Powers 2018 North America Airport
satisfaction study overall traveler
satisfaction climbed to a score of 7 761
on JD Powers 1000 point scale that
marked an all-time high for the short
survey North America airports have been
doing
- job managing passenger volume adding
amenities and keeping travelers moving
despite some noteworthy challenges
keeping hurried people moving ok Jackie
I've been wanting to bring that up ever
since we started talking about this ok I
would like to propose a question we'll
go back to the story in 2 seconds so
you're playing scattegories over the
weekend and everybody John wins in
California by the way everybody voted
against my answer and I am angry about
it still because I think I deserve
justice so if you know scattegories and
you know the rules like you okay so it
was things found in an airport and the
letter was a and I said hurried people
what are your thoughts and my argument
cuz you're really not supposed to use
adjectives like if it's just if people
would have suffice and you're using
hurry to get the H in there for sure and
people would have suffice as an answer
but there are more often than not a lot
of people who are in a hurry at airports
like making their connections missing
their flights delayed running change
change gates like there are hurry and so
we were being very strict on the no
adjectives rule unless it was absolutely
pertinent to the situation but I think
that hurried would be pertinent and
everyone was giving me [ __ ] and I didn't
get the point and I'm just like really
upset about I think you have to put this
into context because this was after you
arguing many many terms also rap also
slamming down other people rational
other people's arguments and using the
basis of adjectives and so at a certain
point and I think I was the judge on
this one and I had given you a lot of
leeway and I put my foot down at hurried
people mostly because everyone else just
had legit answers like a hangar lion
airlines here's the thing
what are they basing this off of because
for the with the top three airports top
three airports the airport with the
highest overall rating was California's
John Wayne that serves Orange County
well that makes sense the airport one of
the secondary airports in the Greater
Los Angeles area earned 815 points
taking ok [ __ ] this mega airports one
Las Vegas McCarran I've been there they
have slot machines of course that's
gonna be the time like it's a good it's
a good airport first sure you've cried
another airport no no I cried at JFK
after coming back from Las Vegas
McCarran came in connection oh I cried
in that Airport too and that was such a
sad that wasn't said out for like yeah
whole entire flight Wow I was 11 11
neglige
I'm done okay um but so McCarran is a
really nice airport but that's our best
airport like we have to step it up well
here's the thing I've had that number
one is Orlando International I've been
there but I don't remember it
I just never three is Detroit it's
subjective because like I its traveler
we could consider LaGuardia the best
Airport even though most people would
consider it the worst it's the smallest
I would base the best Airport based on
once I step off the plane how far of a
walk is it to my car like that's what I
care about
JFK can be considered than um whenever
we can save a [ __ ] check check but
when I got off my bachelor party at p-51
Knight said take a bus just to get to
the baggage claim like no bats doesn't
work for me smaller is better you could
literally not give me a [ __ ] like
piece of fruit I don't want anything
except I want to be close to my game and
I don't want to walk yeah and I want
people to be nice to me and the airport
in Denver is apparently like spooked do
you know about it oh yeah we talked
about this conspiracy theories about it
numbers longest walk ever number 5 is
Dallas Fort Worth which I've also been
to which is a nice airport but like not
anything to write home about number six
is Atlanta which is like a hub for a lot
of Airlines worst Airport Charles
DeGaulle
Paris this is long long walk what's the
best airport in the world probably
except LaGuardia in the world yeah the
best yeah what LaGuardia Airport in
world's are you for real yeah that's
like there's a Wendy's and literally
every day legit every gate is so close
to the curb because we're pleased oh
they're reading me I love it the way
that it is Airport there's nothing there
like if you go there's a one thing we
don't show up to LaGuardia hungry you
guys oh really
la pompe we're at LAX fancy with them
lemonade we went to five stores not a
single tampon ready oh my god la hates
women
no that was so that was so crazy you
want 1 million store it's like Hudson
news at CNBC not a [ __ ] tampon in the
whole place can you believe we're
bleeding oh no like that's so I just
feel like I'm the one hand I feel I can
just step or step up airports because
like come on guys
and then tuck it it should be
exaggerated it's a bench you know guys
right yes on the other hand it's like
airports you know it's got traveling
isn't glamorous anymore like
Airport speaks to the conditions of the
planes and you know what we're just
trying to get from point A to point B
and you know really one Bond pond should
suffice
technically no I couldn't agree more
like this is just an aside and they let
steps wetting our money there lets
fitting our money just like on the
actual plan so you know but I would
prefer you know just sit literally on a
patch of dirt waiting for my flight and
then my actual flight be a first-class
seat do you know any mean I guess it's
unnecessary distribution of funds we
need to circle back redistribute and
then we'll be better off
we gotta get TBG here I wonder what he
thinks is the best Airport in the
country should ask him yeah yeah and
then we'll get to this story and then
we'll bring out the woman of the hour
and everyone's life in the country or in
the world in the country because the
world has much nicer airports than we do
and we're not we can't even compete with
them okay done fifth and final story and
a little bit of stock news and here if
you're interested in I gotta say my
portfolio is doing right this is about
Amazon will consider opening up to three
thousand cash earless stores by 2021
amazon.com is considering a plan to open
as many as three thousand new Amazon go
cash earless stores for Jackie IRA the
punch in the next few years according to
people familiar with the matter an
aggressive and costly expansion that
would threaten convenience chains like
7-eleven quick service sandwich shops
like Subway Panera and mom-and-pop
pizzerias and taco taco trucks I don't
know because those people have people
working there and like you guys I can't
punch them so personally I would not go
to a cashier list or I need someone to
scream out and when like I can't get my
deodorant out of the case cuz apparently
it has like a lot of hardly it's
weaponized yeah I'm like I press the
button no one comes press it again I'm a
mission [ __ ] and then I start screaming
and someone comes in helps but if it's
cuz Sheila said well okay here's the
thing I have to tell you an interesting
experience that I had this game I played
code names it's like the new board game
it's like the trendy board game I was
trying to get it and I wanted to get it
in time for Yom Kippur because like you
can't really do anything else okay
before and I'm just calling all these
toy stores nobody has it nobody has it I
call Amazon books and they had it like
you know they have these weird like
freaking so it's like even their
brick-and-mortar stores are better than
other brick-and-mortar stores so
everyone hates Amazon cuz they're
putting all these companies out of
business the mom-and-pop pharmacy like
I'm sorry mom-and-pop will be fine
because they'll be getting their drugs
so [ __ ] fast and cheap that they
won't be able to believe it now if so
much time to do other things
it's like I'm just so not here for like
the anti Amazon takeover like I'm ready
my legs are spread Amazon tape over
mention it
oh I'm here for the Amazon takeover like
it just they made it so easy for me and
they even offered to hold it for me so
like nobody else can get it like just
they're so in tune with my needs as a
millennial as a woman of the digital age
that I'm not here for all the Amazon
bashing no I'm not bashing Amazon I'm
bashing cashier less situations but do
you know that if Amazon is out they're
just gonna have any like way everyone
read about it you have you leave with
all the items you just walk out and you
were like it's like a scam they you have
like a card in your wallet okay and that
card scans all the items like all the
stickers on everything you stole I can't
[ __ ] with that yeah no it's good it's
good
you just walk CEO Jeff Bezos sees
eliminating mealtime log jams in busy
cities is the best way for Amazon to
reinvent into the brick-and-mortar
shopping experience where most spending
still occurs but he's still
experimenting with the best format a
convenience store that sells fresh
prepared foods as well as a limited
grocery store selection similar to
7-eleven you know it's time for a
7-eleven revamp I'm sorry you guys like
it's not cute in there no 711s are so
necessary and so disgusting I used to
live across the street for more
necessary evil yeah and like just
because they have a fountain soda
machine it's like we have to have them
but like when you walk to the front and
they have like that those hot dogs
roasting and you just know that there's
a venereal disease it's so disgusting
the floors are so dirty like when I go
in there with Theo I picked Theo up and
like Theo literally walks through the
trash filled streets of New York but he
won't walk through a 7-eleven Wow and
everything you get from there is like
stale right so I appreciate like Amazon
forcing everyone to step up their game
or to step out and also voila
we don't have what was in the city or in
New York which is like really upsetting
Amazon she partnered with Wawa and like
for their for their like recipes well
she just opened like a big-ass store in
New York and like I would be there every
day for lunch but then it's like that
then it's not a convenience store
because convenience is like on every
corner right Wawa is so clean like it's
crazy and the mac and cheese was that
little machine where you order your
sandwiches like brilliant like that is
an Amazon level type of machine I
completely agree so much so many
t-shirts Hobie fest like I just love
Wawa and they had a really nice chilled
pasta salad which I thoroughly enjoy
honestly primary Terry too many cherry
tomatoes bit
well I use Terry Tomatoes in this
category and they gave it to you four
things I found at a salad bar with the
sea cherry tomato then everyone's
arguing it's a to me that I was arguing
on your behalf
yeah you were I mean we were on the same
side I just let's ask people with this
thing about Easter okay so there was a
category ethnic foods the letter is e
Olivia goes first she says Ethiopian
food so and everyone gets to turn no
problem then I go and I say Eastern
European food and everyone's up in arms
because a they say they were arguing
that Eastern European is not a cuisine
and B even if is if it is it sounds
specific cuz you were mentioning like
pierogies and that's looks like that
they're polish it's not polish shoot
it's not like but the Jackie presented
the argument would you have accepted
Asian food would you have accepted
Mediterranean of course of course they
wouldn't have even looked twice but they
were like no it's not country and it
said by Sheree Jackie was gonna get
double points because Eastern European
is two E's and by the way I did give
myself the points and she deserved it I
oh my god it was brilliant it was blood
like they were like what's an Eastern
European restaurant like Veselka
and they're like what's knee surgery at
Veselka
yep pierogies [ __ ] okay are we ready is
that it for LeAnn okay thank God okay so
here's what's gonna happen
Leeanne Locken it's just like spritzing
herself up in the back I'm sure she's
moisturizing her hands and we're gonna
go get her we're gonna take a brief
break two to three minutes going to
snack take a PEZ talk to Sally at the
water cooler whatever you have to do we
will be back and LeAnn will be here so
if you've a question for her I have the
YouTube stream pulled up right here
we'll ask her we're also taking the
questions you guys left on Instagram so
we're gonna recap everything from last
night's episode of Real Housewives of
Dallas and watch rappin's live so we
will see you in just a minute
you
ladies and gentlemen
they're just hands please welcome
Leeanne Locken yeah oh my god we love a
work I love how much you can trace bad
like that is are you kidding so epic and
I can't even have you seen Andy do it
yes what happens live I'm gonna stop
you're ruining it for me and you are
watch oppened live last night right yeah
oh is that the best time ever
oh I had a I got to break bottles over
Brendan's head it was awesome the first
one they like talked I was like oh but
it doesn't hurt to take I died yeah well
they told me it was fake so what do you
actually drink when you on that job yeah
yeah everyone everyone does yeah okay so
your shots key oh that's was their
actual shots in it I've heard there's
water in it no I had alcohol I'm sure
you could request anything you rather
but aren't you kind of a meow meow if
you have worse you got to do it yeah
ever not so yeah well we're so glad
you're back we love you I love y'all and
we love you and I love your hair
thank you have really been experimenting
with your looks and I have to say we
that was probably the thing we got the
most questions about is do you do your
own hair and makeup when you film like a
regular scenes yes but in the interview
portions that's done by professionals
yeah
leave that to the perfect I pick pony
pony colorful pony gel that went down to
your ass Oh Mike did that um dear Clark
my hair salon got it I bought the hair
and then jerk I told him what you know
Beyonce and just coming with that
crimped big huge like nine-foot ponytail
and I was like that's what I want to do
for the party it was great and then I
did it with like three different colors
on the end yeah right and then you have
also of your purple pony tail but if
you're a nerd do you love that that so
Massey Bach
so I wanted so I wanted my third look
which they didn't let me do I wanted to
do gold foil and then have have glitter
coming down oh my goodness but they were
like no it's too much for interviews
it's a lot but like yes fern event
season finale we could see it okay but
it's just watches of the show we really
appreciate all the glitz and the glam
that you bring yes because it's like
you're bringing a lot of effort you care
about it like you're bringing the drama
and you're bringing the glam so I
appreciate that you know what I got so
tired of hearing how like you know I
live in a trailer park so I was like
okay here I'm gonna Park it up for you
right so you
desert is notice we were talking about
it before like all of your looks a bus
yeah I had fun I had fun this season for
the first time you know I walked into
the season in a really different place
and really in control of myself and I
think that really is dull few people
that I was so in control but what really
changed from last season to this season
that like you wanted to take control
they have different reaction first of
all who all on the show is challenged to
get better every year you every year
have I said to anyone else you might
want to stop drinking a little too no
never
might want to go back to school and get
educated okay so I took the challenge
not just because they challenged it but
because I'd love to be better you know
watch yourself on the show and you're
like yeah it can be quite humbling yeah
yeah and you can't deny it I mean it's
better yeah yeah so you know I'm like
and then you know also I season two
reunion I said I want to go take
behavioral management I don't want to
like constantly go off on everyone I
want to be able to articulate how I'm
feeling without without being hijacked
right and so I started doing research
real research on the brain and the
amygdala is a genuine it's the frontal
lobe and it's your fight flight or
freeze it's your survivor part of your
brain so when your amygdala is triggered
no blood flow goes to any other part of
your brain everything shuts down and all
goes to the amygdala so you survive
that's how we've survived that's why
dinosaurs aren't here and we are the
problem with that is it's called
emotional hijacking your amygdala
emotionally hijacks you and if a plant
touches you you may come on up you know
you know you're like okay it's not that
big of a deal you know but you're in a
heightened state and so now that you've
now that I've learned I could take
behavioral management all I was never
gonna doing it it's not gonna change my
behavior isn't gonna change I have to
manage and control my brains so I
learned you could shrink your amygdala
monks because they meditate for so many
hours of the day have it's seen to
shrink now I will say that it you know
going into next season I I will take you
to peak Neurosci
and you will get to see visual displays
of what my brain looks like when I'm
looking at a peaceful ocean and you are
going to be blown oh that's so crazy and
they say you can't learn anything from
Bravo oh no no I let me tell you
something you're gonna learn I'm gonna
make you learn well I feel like
specifically last night but just a
season in general I think I've
personally just as a viewer notice to
ship in your relationship with Deandra
yeah can you tell me how do you know
Deandra and how long have you known her
sure um I was out one night and at a
fundraiser for a mutual friend Kim
Gatlin and she was in the back with
Jeremy and I knew her like we'd seen
each other we'd been at events together
but we weren't close and she was crying
and I walked over and I said what is
wrong and I guess her maid of honor was
like going off on her in text message
and I go here took her phone deletes
block handed her her phone back she goes
what did she say and I go doesn't matter
it wasn't you you don't would you want
that in your head you're getting married
true so you met her right before she got
mad like I mean she said will you stand
with me you stand for me that night I
thought it meant well you just stand up
for me I didn't know it meant I had
literally said and then like be your
[ __ ] friend right but you know that's
so cute we really like your friends you
may - right now in the show it's going
through muddy waters but all friendships
have to be tested at a certain point and
how you come out really is a true sign
of friendship so we're selected a right
now oh no what
well okay so last night we went through
a rough patch it seems like you guys
like awkwardly made up at the end like
there was some resolution yeah because
she was upset that you were told to
carry a bag to my dollar what she told
me right did you tell you not to tell
anyone no she was drunk and crying and
I'm thinking to myself [ __ ] I gotta
solve this problem so coming from a
place where background I'm like we got
returned I am like you gotta help me
we got to get this stuff returned it's
not fair she was drinking and shopping
yeah you know somebody needs to pay for
this [ __ ] it not her and Brandi didn't
and then and then sadly because I was so
stressed and heightened I said she's
upstairs crying right now and she's only
got $200 her bagman cow and then all of
it gets twisted again I say things
always end up what's it like on the
heart that's so funny because when right
before you got him you're like I feel
like every time Leon comes here I'm like
mad at her for something and then she
just explains it to me they all make
sense yeah Rinat really that really does
make sense if you read my blog I'm gonna
tell you I poor Rachel who has to edit
them watch our blogs or you know publish
them she has to go through him and make
sure everything we say is true right
fact checker she she it takes forever to
do mine cuz I'm like well did you just
say up up up up up Papa and and she's
like I always have to go check and I go
I'm always on average how long do you
spend a week on your blog takes me about
two to three hours to write it I sit
down I want if I'm at home I'll watch it
and write it right then cuz I want to be
done with it
I don't suffer it like I did years pass
I write it I'm done with it I send it
and then I go back to life right I can't
I don't want to do this 24/7 but so at
present day you and DeAndre are not on
good terms
no she's got some doozy of some rumors
going on about me in Dallas
got it and so what is your take on her
whole situation with her mom are you
friendly with her mom do you know her
mom I'm the one who nicknamed her mama
Dee got it and what are your thoughts
what's your take on the whole thing
dee is right okay Deandra has never
earned a dime I mean her Dee's belated
husband provided for dandruff for the
rest of her life I mean when she's like
I pay my own bills you don't pay
anything you know Jane has Deandra
separated her company from her mom's yet
oh and she's been talking about it for
years
and she still works for him on it yeah
and her mom does all the work right but
she's always filming at the office how
does her mom feel about the show how
does he get Angier get involved in the
show there
you for me got it and what does mom
think about the show I haven't asked her
our relationship is going to come to
right position right now got it well me
and check you're always talking about
Cameron and you we were just talking
about this before and you're like a
camera defender and I appreciate that
you're a good friend
and I hope that if anyone would does
anything about it Matty would defend
them as well but just as it I I wouldn't
argue straight as a viewer I find her to
be like annoying and I think she
probably knows how she comes off it's
like a little condescending and judgy
and like not super fun I would love to
know a how you met you met her through
the show through carry through the show
okay and you love her yeah and here's
the thing you guys got to remember like
when Cameron was first thinking about
joining the show I mean she heard from
some people
what a crazy she was told LeAnn's just
gonna attack you for no reason on set
and then thank God because Cameron is
truly a part of society and lives across
the street from someone else who is a
dear friend who was like a shark of a
lawyer married to a brain surgeon was
like girl she is not gonna she's defense
herself she doesn't attack anybody and
just Cameron listen to her and then gave
me a chance right so she didn't come in
like freaked out and Cameron is a part
of this like hi it's made very clear
especially this season like the type of
family that she comes around and I find
it so odd that they would kind of let
her go on the show because the show does
have a reputation she had to really
really Cameron is a huge housewife fan
right so she wanted to do it but it was
a lot of massaging in that way to get
everything set up so any time she says
or does something do you think that it's
under the lens of like one what little
percent cams mom thing or what's the
same another quartz mom Yeah right Jimmy
there I wouldn't piss off Jimmy right
listen
I mean Jimmy's a rock star yeah yeah
it's Jimmy please with Cameron's
behavior on the show so far yeah and I
think Jimmy comes to Cameron's defense
later on in the season well she could
she'll be interesting internet will be
in I love to see a good mama on mama oh
my mom exciting okay so some of your
other relationships with the women okay
you and Carrie had
made amends so far on the season I'm
here for the friendship me too and where
do you stand today I'm here for the
friendship cuz I think it brings us one
step closer to Leanne and Brandi finally
reuniting Brandi Stephanie carry for
something I want all of em easy Andrea
and you know I don't want to come out no
good I want everyone to get along and
sometimes you guys really do so do I
like in Beavercreek like things were
good until I went to bed right right I
would love to hear your thoughts in that
argument of Cameron feeling upset that
she didn't know about the baby because I
thought that was just outrageous it's
two different arguments cam is arguing
about the word bash Stephanie is arguing
about the intention behind what Cameron
was doing right it's two different
arguments I wasn't I want your opinion
on a Cameron initially saying to Brandi
I felt hurt that you didn't ever you
adopted okay she was she was genuinely
hurt she thought everyone else knew but
her she felt like she was left out oh
come on
friends yes they were very year when she
found out that not everyone else knew
they were friends Oh Cameron and Brandi
were friends like off season they were
close okay but when she found out that
not everyone else knew just Stephanie
and Cary like then it became no longer
about that not everyone knew then it
became about the lie and I understand
that Stephanie under pressure did
something that she would not normally do
but in our world lies especially in the
state of Texas Liars don't last so
grayza
it's really a dangerous you can get out
of anything you can get out of anything
by simply not addressing the question
okay oh my gosh I figured it out
Brandi's having a baby
are you sure cam I've seen her and she
didn't get she didn't look fat she look
pregnant but I don't know cam you're
silly I'm can I get you a cocktail what
can I go get you see it's different you
just defer yeah but I think Stephanie
got caught up and and you know and I get
both sides I really do because you know
Steph and I have come a long way yeah
are you guys still I'm loving the
evolution are you guys still
moving in in a lair okay I mean she
texted me just yesterday saying good
luck on the mall toast every week she
texts me and says are you okay mm-hmm
are you good with this so nice or you do
you need anything and then good luck
with everything you're doing I know
you're doing watch was live good luck
and I I have to say you know the for me
I think the balance for this show is
that while I am very hurt and you're
gonna get to watch my heartbreak on
camera not even rich could console me in
terms of what you trenches of
relationships that I thought were there
that maybe may have never been there to
the sadness of that to the possibility
of I never thought I would be where I am
with Cary and Stephanie and I literally
get choked up about it because it's I
feel grateful I feel blessed I feel
blessed because I did a lot that I I
wish I hadn't hmm and yet they their
gracious forgiven you that's great I
love it I always find that housewives
franchises are better when everyone gets
along but they think that they have to
argue because that's TV but I thought I
was better that's why the Beaver Creek
episodes were so good because you girls
really have fun like when you're
together yeah and it's fun to watch your
liquor hilarious oh my god Carrie and I
were picking up every shirt in the play
it was so much fun yeah that's so funny
and you've got the only person that
you're really not well and to DeAndre
its Brandon still is a no no more work
on it well work on her are you open to
it always okay always it only requires
one thing that you understand that if
you're going to challenge me to grow I
have to challenge the same of you
okay you can't expect me to grow and
then you stay the same and yet we should
be in a different place what do you
think grant Brandi needs to grow in
terms of I think it would behoove Brandi
to do what I do which is go to therapy
on a weekly basis and really learn about
herself and why she reacts certain ways
and
some of the stuff that she does isn't
necessary brandy has so much more to
offer than what she believes she has to
offer
and I think that insecurity brings out a
very mean side of brandy and I know
because my insecurities brought out a
mean side of me not like I'm saying
something that I'm not aware of in my
own self right like you got to be
self-aware if in addition and I don't
think she's self-aware okay and I'd love
to see her more self-confident have you
set a wedding date yes you have
how far out array like you mean three to
six months six to nine months nine to
twelve months or more Oh shame on you
for asking will you tell me Alf camera
yeah okay that's all I care about
and some viewer questions for you okay
I'm gonna rattle them off during season
one of housewives you were very involved
in multiple charities there was a big
emphasis on charity yes are you still
involved with all those charities but
you guys just don't you like film that
part as much code twofold question is it
true that when the show first was
becoming a show it was a it wasn't a
Housewives franchise it was like a
charity Dallas show it was so we were
first season we were supposed to be a
show based off of women who do charity
and that they that's how they all
socialized together at that point in
time of the original of us I did the
most charity care II did the second and
Stephanie did some but so you created a
show based off of my life whoa and then
what happened was the word charity got
said so much when I should have said
nonprofit right and I'm a servant I'm a
servant to our community I'm serving
those in need because that is what I was
doing so you asked me about charities we
thought we will be filming some you will
see some this season actually I was very
grateful that Bravo stepped in and said
we were wrong to take that away from you
we want to see you do that and so you
will see me at several you know
obviously most of them will be based
around my LGBTQ community I'll be
getting married in my LGBTQ cathedral so
has the show brought you like more
opportunities to do charity elsewhere
yeah I feel speaking I'm going next week
where you la I'm doing Christmas in
September at the Abbey three moves to go
please bring up toy if you live in LA
please come to the abbey and bring a toy
during September the Children's Hospital
runs out of toys for the children and so
we're doing a toy drive that is so funny
isn't that wonderful yeah is wonderful
and I love that I me too you know that's
like my thing yeah no that's great cuz I
mean you had me at the Abbey but then
you brought we're helping children and
I'm like can I deliver the toys that
sounds really fun and really cute I just
it's me yeah sorry me okay next up who
was the housewife from any franchise
that you're dying to me dying to meet um
I just met Lisa I mean I would watch
Lisa Vanderpump
what were your thoughts on her we hate
her um she was tired when when she came
into no no they'd been a long day we
were eating dinner at tom tom okay ian
was very nice he came outside and took a
picture with amazing it looks really
must have deep fried olives must know
you think but I'm gonna tell you what
nothing like olives well yeah
panties get wet it's good but I hate
olives like the smell me don't don't I
don't know that they even they don't
features good chicken wing okay to fold
to that question who's a someone from
Bravo
we're housewives or otherwise who you've
met who like kind of disappointing he
wasn't so nice well this isn't much oven
time you don't get to play the fifth set
I I think it was City day were for I was
recently at the OK Magazine party and I
was a little disappointed that and I
know they were filming so I get it cuz
I've been in that scenario but I felt
like some of the New York girls were
yeah they definitely seemed like they
won did not want to be bothered and then
but then my boss fee is like if you
don't want to be bothered why come to a
party totally when you're filming get
back in the car and go home
Dallas is such a small town when you're
filming is it like if you're in a
crowded restaurant is it awkward what is
the damage oh my co-executive producer
Sam is excellent at this and she warns
all of our particular do sirs and all of
our crew when we film at an event you
have to give me 30 minutes to go around
and take pictures and say hello to
people this is what I do
this is part of me saying thank you for
attending this event for supporting this
charity that I love and for watching our
show so you're going to allow me to do
this or we can not go like I have rules
this is my rule you don't take away my
one-on-one connection with people that's
one of the things that I love so you
will you will see more events coming up
Bravo
really stepped in and said we want to
show the anaphor that's that's great um
who's the most fun house I have to get
drunk with oh I'm gonna either go with
Kelly daughter Erika Jayne but I haven't
been definitely Jane Kelly died she was
a good time I cannot keep up with Kelly
that is so funny I am like she knows she
shot so much younger so oh yeah that's
so interesting she can go for longer
what are you gonna be for Halloween this
year
no I haven't yet
maybe I'll put a patch over my eye and
go as a pirate with rich or go as rich
no use to base Redhead brunette maybe
you have ten maybe I'll just write $200
on one single bill and goes to Andres
bank account deceased I thought you were
gonna say something else but that was so
much better can you everyone by the way
in the studio is on the floor yeah sure
but this is live television people what
are the best and worst parts about
filming the show um the best part is I
love what I do I think everything that
I've done in my entire life has created
developed me to be a really good
housewife and part of what I love about
doing this show is I only want to get
better watching the other people when
y'all watch Housewives you watch it too
look at the storyline I'm like no she
just called her a ha ha and then walked
in the other one was like I don't like
that I'm like I got to do that right
this is awesome I'm learning Jesus take
a note right okay well your side
interviews are definitely elevated with
each season just in terms the way that
you look but also like um your verbiage
I don't even know what you're saying
have you calling Leanna
yeah have you watched the ones on bran
bravotv.com no no go to bravotv.com
there's one that's called unseen
interview footage okay and I'm just like
you know you can put tiara around snake
but it's still rough night nobody what
are you saying I would love to know what
other things you proposed as your
tagline what does your tagline this
season
that's a good one I state that day that
was a given I I was really kind of by
the time it hit I was like to say it I
just don't care
yeah the tag lines in Texas are really
good there's a lot of fodder there yeah
yeah there's a lot of like Texas
analogies yeah it's well because last
season when I did write my tagline which
they had to shrink because it was a
little bit larger last season what I
wanted it to be was um I'm an authentic
Texan there's no bull about me but you
mess with me
it's oh yeah that is a little it's a
little long yeah the gist of it came out
yeah Texan album Oh noble all horns no
you have great ones I think that I mean
my Liana I don't know where they come
from
I mean rich is like he's like I'm gonna
write a book now well you know I and I
just recently realized that the goat
zebra thing was probably about DeAngelis
that you know I at one point but that
they're using in the off footage is um
you know you ask me if I'm missing a
zebra I don't know when I turned around
it was a go I mean was there a zebra cuz
all I could see as I can go what I love
it you know you remind me up Miley Cyrus
is dad in Hannah Montana he was southern
like he's always yes and there's an
outer tire than a tire
well you know you know the southern
things there's a lot of southern ways
that people don't get like but also
thing you you use those and then you
make up your own which is just wonderful
yeah rich thinks I'm insane I love it if
you were in on Daoist which Real
Housewives cast would you like to be on
Atlanta totally it's challenge I I
really get bored easy I'm a gem and I'm
fast I got a super super sonic so for me
I need to be somewhere where there's a
challenge okay fair it like a game of
Survivor if you had to vote one lady off
of Real Housewives of Dallas who would
it be
yeah oh but just I'm not yeah okay no so
let me tell you something you know what
here's the thing about me while all my
other cast may band together year after
year to try to remove Leeanne the
reality is not afraid of any of them
leave them all on [ __ ] ten more bring
some people in from other cities I don't
care yeah I'm not afraid like you don't
understand I've already faced it trust
me I've seen Satan you know what he says
uh-oh I don't want her you can have her
she's too hot for me you're back yeah I
have one more final question for you um
has the roundup giving you a piece of
their business or to blow jobs do you
have for all the joy of having someone
else to have to do all that um no they
the best dollar jello shots we're great
jello shots and they are like they
weren't Everclear and kool-aid oh wow
like three and you are like I can there
any day and from some young bangs so
epic like I just uh can't thank you
enough for just like being yourself and
giving me just like so many things to
say like you get to success of the
roundup I know the boys who did it yeah
Austin they work quite well yes they do
like you're just so epic thank you sir
for everything that you do and you know
like a lot for you to put your life out
there but you you bring it yeah I know
that we're love Dallas it's like even
though it's one of the newer franchises
it is so good some of the older
franchises are like suffering from a bit
of staleness okay can always count on
Dallas even on not like a premium
episode it's great even so nothing
happens in everyone's getting along
doesn't like they do it looks like so
much fun
good yes I love it I actually get along
more I think I wish listen the whole
purpose of the anchor room was to go in
and have real conversations about you I
have to say after you know oh my god
it's so much fun but she no here's the
thing
Kerry and Deandra like took base got
walked in the room before ahead of time
and I had like certain things I wanted
to do like those mirrors on the wall I
wanted us to write
all of our insecurities in front of each
other and then smash them
that's key and grow together yeah like
that was a took care of it first right
everybody just walked in start smashing
G like this not how this therapy works
Oh interesting the plates were cute
Cameron's simple life was hilarious oh
my god sorry
I think that's hilarious and when she
said oh my god they booked they're not
even on leashes well so yes she has some
redeeming moments but I can't look at
all the other on a leash really yeah
that's yeah yeah I see what you're
saying
like here's the thing I don't like her
but I value your opinion so the jury's
out whatever Leanne says to do I do
because they're lovely and so whatever
you tell me to do I'll do give her a
chance I know she's I I think she's kind
of a genius look at a different look
through a different perspective you did
say that the last time you were here
okay so because she insulates herself
she only knows her own world in a
positive way whereas some people make
their world all about them and want all
of us to make their world about them as
well she does it in a positive way you
know I don't know her not knowing kind
of fly commercial that was hilarious
yeah oh my god do I get the car before I
get the bags
that's really funny I mean but it's real
bad yeah no I mean I'm laughing final
question but your dogs eat Sparkle dog
food cheap has has city gets edge no no
he'll a pink poop I did not go out and
we squirrels eat the poop nine rich
cannot pick up dog poop cuz he you can
only see out of one eye no cuz he throws
up oh it's so disgusting you can see a
body cut in half on a railroad track but
he cannot pick up dog I mean disgusting
oh that's so funny
we drive sweetie I'm so happy for you
guys I really hope your any money like
tomorrow because I'll be there if you
need me to I'll stay with you one I will
show you a picture when we're done of
him he used all of the medical tape to
write out on my bathroom mirror I love
you infinity ha with an exclamation
point and then he texted me after he
takes a picture it goes I really hope I
don't need any medical tape anytime soon
oh that's so cute well thank you so much
for being here everyone make sure to
follow you in at Leeanne Locken on
Instagram Twitter all the stuff be nice
Facebook all the stuff thank you guys
commissioning chibok it's fun I don't
block you know we have a cast members
blocking right now I don't know how was
it who's getting ripped to shreds danja
she is she I'm kind of like on her money
the other girl I'm from I'm her for her
right now until she crosses me
ok the reckoning is coming I don't thank
you so much for watching the morning
toast we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on Facebook and
YouTube so make sure you're subscribed
there and then we're also available it's
a podcast in the podcast app out in
SoundCloud Spotify all the places you
shouldn't have our time finding it if
you're smart thank you all so much for
being here pizza we're back tomorrow at
Jerry O'Connell
you